There's a reason texting attracts teens.
Texting is easy for kids because you can do a lot of things besides calling and stuff like that.
But it can become addicting.
Take Nikki Brown, she could not stop sending text messages.
I text morning, noon, and night, probably about three to five thousand a month.
Her habit is so obsessive that some psychiatrists would classify it as a mental illness,...
...a compulsive - impulsive disorder.
An article in the American Journal of Psychiatry...
...suggests successive e-mailing, texting, gaming,...
...and viewing pornography online are serious public health issues,...
...and should be recognized as symptoms of a clinical disorder.
People with this addiction may lie about how much texting, emailing, or gaming they do.
Dr. Ronald Davis of the American Medical Association.
It can replace people's sense of family and sense of community.
But you can be in your home all the time in the basement or in your bedroom...
...gaming in a virtual world where there are no limits.
In some countries, Internet gaming is more of a concern than obsessive texting.
The South Korean government considers gaming a serious public health issue.
The Chinese government now limits the amount of time people can spend on a computer...
...to play these games.
Carol Pearson, VOA news.